آه ، لذا قمنا بإحضار البنجسو على
الطاولة ونخبر الضيوف فقط أن هذا هو
البنجسو وقمنا بإسقاطه لذلك هناك
تحطم إنه في الأساس في
وعاء شوكولاتة ويتعطل والناس يشعرون
بالصدمة تمامًا في عالم
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  الناس على instagram
ثم أصبح شائعًا من خلال ذلك ، لذا
جاء الجميع وبدأوا في
طلب حلوى سماش ،
لذا فإن البينجسو هو حلوى كورية تقليدية جدًا
كما هو معروف اليوم
ولكن الجذور كانت في الواقع في الصين وفي
الصين أكلوا قطع الثلج أو الفواكه على
الجليد
إنه يشبه الثلج أو الثلج المجروش
مع الحليب المكثف مع شراب الفاكهة
مع الهلام ومع الكثير والكثير من
الفاكهة ،
يمكنك تناوله طوال العام ولكنه ناجح بشكل أساسي
في
الصيف
[الموسيقى]
بشكل أساسي عندما
يأتي فصل الربيع في الشتاء ويحل موسم الربيع
تمر بموسم الفراولة في كوريا ، لذا
في ذلك الوقت ،
نحن نصنع بنجسو الفراولة ثم تقدمه
مع الآيس كريم الطري ، لذا فهو
منعش حقًا وعليك فقط
أن  احفر بالملعقة التي تعرفها
والأشخاص الذين يحبونها ،
لذا ما نفعله هنا هو أننا نستخدم كتلة كاملة
من الجليد تأتي من اليابان
فقط لأن جودة الثلج أيضًا
للحفاظ على قوامها كما هي في محلوقها
مهمة جدًا
أكثر من  جودة الثلج فقط هي
أيضًا العملية ، لذا إذا كانت لديك
العملية الصحيحة لتصفية المياه
، فلديك مجمد فائق ، يمكنك حتى
صنعه هنا ولكن نظرًا لعدم توفر
كل هذه المرافق ، يكون الماء
عادةً يحتوي على محتوى ملحي  المياه
في اليابان أكثر
نقاءً ، والبنغسو
شيء تحفره وتشاركه مع الناس ، لذلك
لا يجب أن تكون
نظيفة جدًا وحريصة على التفاصيل على الطلاء
، المهم هو مشاركتها
وهو أمر ممتع
تعرفه  لذلك بدأنا بملمس
المونجو ، ثم تم بنائه ،
ثم عندما بدأت في الحفر بشكل أساسي
كان كل شيء ينهار نوعًا
ما ، لذلك لم يكن الأمر
سهلاً على الضيوف ، لذلك نقول إنك تعرف
ماذا  سوف نحضر
قشرة صالحة للأكل عبارة عن قشرة شوكولاتة ، ثم
نقوم بتحطيمها أمام الغاز ،
ونقوم أيضًا بعمل نسخة مثيرة جدًا
منها باستخدام الماتشا وهذا شيء
مختلف تمامًا ، لذلك نستخدم
الماتشا نسميها ماتشا بينغسو آه ولها فانيليا
بها  القليل من عنصر كعكة الجبن
ثم مجموعة كاملة من
آيس كريم ماتشا بودرة الماتشا وما إلى ذلك
[موسيقى]